well i think something really uh big
that's different
is donald trump because in 2016 he was
running as an outsider
he said look i don't have 50 years of
political baggage i'm not paying back
favors i'm an outsider i'm a businessman
i know how to balance a budget i know
how to cut spending
and i know how to you know get get stuff
done basically and i'll bring the troops
home
and so that's why the polls got it wrong
because uh
people voted for him who had never voted
or who hadn't voted for 20 years
and so now uh it's four years later and
we can see that
he's acted pretty much like all the
professional politicians that he's
increased the deficit he's increased the
debt uh still hasn't brought the troops
home
so now i think that maybe people will
say you know
maybe republicans are beyond hope
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report as always guys don't forget to
subscribe
to our channel and click that pesky
notification bell
and joining me today is a senior
lecturer in psychology at clemson
university and
libertarian presidential candidate joe
jorgensen welcome to the reuben report
oh so glad to be here thanks for having
me well i'm thrilled to have you
and i know for sure that my audience is
thrilled to have you because i've
received roughly
four billion tweets saying why haven't
you had joe jorgensen on
so for the record uh we have been trying
to make this happen for a while
and we finally finally did make it
happen we weren't avoiding you and you
were not avoiding us
is that fair to say okay you just you
just couldn't catch up to the bus huh
back there
chasing my bus
[Laughter]
you've got a powered you've got a super
powered bus over there okay so
there's a lot of stuff that i want to
talk to you about and
i think you know a bit about my sort of
political evolution and probably most of
my
political stances you you may not know
that i actually did vote for the
libertarian candidate in the last
election i did vote for gary johnson i
had gary johnson
on my show i i like gary johnson um
i don't think he was you know the
strongest libertarian candidate
in a year that there was a moment for it
um so i guess my first question that'll
probably set up everything else
is if it didn't work in 2016 when
so many people were frustrated what is
different
this time what why should the
libertarians have hoped this time
well i think something really uh big
that's different
is donald trump because in 2016 he was
running as an outsider
he said look i don't have 50 years of
political baggage i'm not paying back
favors i'm an outsider i'm a businessman
i know how to balance a budget i know
how to cut spending
and i know how to you know get get stuff
done basically and i'll bring the troops
home
and so that's why the polls got it wrong
because uh
people voted for him who had never voted
or who hadn't voted for 20 years
and so now it's four years later and we
can see that he's acted pretty much like
all the professional politicians that
he's increased the deficit he's
increased the debt
uh still hasn't brought the troops home
so now i think that maybe people will
say
you know uh maybe republicans are beyond
hope now libertarians have known that
republicans are beyond hope since 1971
and that's why the party was formed
after
richard nixon stopped acting like a
republican but maybe now the republican
voters
and let me say there are many fine
republican voters who want smaller
government
it's republican politicians who aren't
giving it to them
and so maybe after having an outsider
come in
a businessman who supposedly compounds
the budget maybe
they'll say you know it's time for a
real outsider so what would you say
to the conservatives or the republicans
who want smaller government they want
lower taxes and they're looking and
they're going okay trump
did cut some taxes he got rid of some
regulation we're clearly not going into
other wars at the moment we're bringing
troops home
that are basically looking at that stuff
and going hey
trump did give us a bunch of the stuff
that that we want yes is the budget
going up yeah but the budget
or the deficit going up yeah but it
always seems to go up
do you think he's done anything right
from a libertarian perspective
well he has cut some regulations however
i'd like to point out
that a tax cut is also
going to be possibly an increase in
spending if they don't do anything to
make that up so
uh again he the the deficits are going
up either way yeah
yeah the exactly the bottom line is
spending's going up and that's what
counts
even if we're not paying for it this
year we'll be paying for it next year 10
years from now
20 years from now and that's that's what
matters
are you constantly amazed as a
libertarian that telling people
we want you to keep more of your money
is not more of a winning ticket i mean i
think when people
really hear it if you bash them over the
head with it over and over and over
again and you're like yeah
we want you to have your money not them
i think they do get it but it seems like
it's such an easy sale and yet for some
reason people just don't
understand it or don't absorb it
yes well what really frustrates me are
people like bill gates or oprah winfrey
who say yeah the government doesn't take
enough of my money
you know tax me more but look at what
bill gates does he starts the bill and
melinda gates foundation
uh does you know good work and uh oprah
winfrey opens up her own school
right over in africa well if they think
that the government
can do a better job than they can why
are they starting their own foundations
why not simply turn all of that money
over to the federal government
and so i think that actions speak louder
than words and if even they
aren't turning their money over i think
that that should send a message to
everybody else that hey
the government doesn't do a good job i
can't think of much that the government
does a better job
than the private sector and i think that
bill gates and
oprah winfrey and all these other
liberals who want bigger government i
think that they're just proving our
point for us
so what do you think is going on in
their heads there is it is it just
is it misguidedness or is it guilt
or is it that they know that the the
machine and the media will like them
more
if they take these positions i'm
hoping it's ignorance the true sense of
the word
ignorance because a lot of people just
don't understand how things work
and that's one of the biggest
compliments that i get from people
i just you know non-libertarian friends
after they meet me they say you know
what
i read the news differently now i look
at things differently now
they don't you know for instance yeah we
cut taxes okay what about spending
uh so you can look at things in a
superficial way and think things are
going great without
you know the understanding or the
underlying what's going on
uh beneath it all yeah does does the
thing that frustrates you
the most uh have anything to do with the
sort of
simplistic way we look at politics where
you know half of the country
seems to think that if you tell them
they're getting something for free they
seem to think it actually
is free and combating that notion
is almost impossible you say free health
care you say free education
you know free money now literally free
money it's like
that combating oh but you do have to pay
for it
that's just not what we do publicly very
well
yes i would have thought that with the
obama phone remember those
basically what obama's going to reach
into his back pocket and buy everybody a
phone
and that's what i've been telling
everybody about these 1200 checks that
they're getting
is that money is coming from somewhere
and
i i know that you know supposedly there
was a hold up because donald trump
wanted his name written on the actual
check well
i don't think that that check is coming
from his back pocket or his private
checking account it's coming from us
so somehow they give us money and and
and make it you know
make it seem like it's santa claus or
something but what's frustrating
is the that they take our taxes
out our income taxes so that we get a
tax
refund every year after april and so it
looks like we're getting something
and i wish they had never started that
practice i don't think we'd be where we
are now
if people actually had the had to feel
the pain
and right now people feel the pain when
they're teenagers and then they quickly
forget you know so many times i hear
about somebody's
uh you know friends uh kid who goes to
work
i'm like wait a minute i work 20 hours
this week
where's this money going and it's like
well welcome to the world of being an
adult welcome to the world of taxes
and so it feels painful then but by the
time you're 30 40 years old and
it's grown and grown you've kind of
forgotten about it so
yeah so i can't talk to the libertarian
presidential candidate without
mentioning the
phrase that everyone says that getting
libertarians to agree on anything is
like hurting a bunch of cats
and i think when people think of the
party
the party itself they think of the naked
guy running on stage all the
the crazy characters and everything else
what do you think the libertarians
have perhaps done wrong if the ideas are
right well i think
what we all did wrong decades ago
was try to focus on philosophy
although i think the libertarian party
pretty much had to do it because
when the party started 40 years ago we
didn't have
um well actually more than 40 years ago
50 years ago we didn't have
all of these outlets we didn't have all
these educational groups all these
research institutions so we pretty much
had to do it all so we focus on
philosophy
and in fact it's interesting reading the
original libertarian
papers that talk about how we shouldn't
even run candidates you know we're a
political party and maybe not run
candidates because our job is to educate
well now we no longer need to do that
and so that's why i'm so happy to be the
candidate and i'm really glad that i was
able to draw together
both the pragmatic caucus and the
radical caucus
who somewhat agreed on me because what
i'm trying to do is i'm trying to give a
practical message
to the american public and not talk
about self-ownership
not talk about me but talk about okay
you know what
you're having a hard time paying your
mortgage because the your health care
bills are so high
you know or we hear about people being
sent off
around the world and you know your
friends your neighbors your relatives
being killed
in a senseless war so let's talk about
things that they care about
and take off our philosophy hat and put
on our political hat
yeah do you think that there's a better
chance
because of what you said earlier that
this is the year to make the dent
because
it seems to me like there was in the
summer before the election
there was suddenly this buzz for a few
weeks of like oh
maybe there's this libertarian thing
that could happen
or at least i mean i did a video in
august
when i said that i'm going to vote for
gary johnson i said really look maybe he
can't win but i at least want to get the
guy
in a debate now you did not get in the
debate
uh so i'm guessing you're not too happy
about that but
what about combating the system like can
you just talk about what it's been like
to just combat
the two-party thing oh
it's been an uphill battle and what
people don't realize
is well the one thing that i hate is how
the libertarian party is put
as one of the other third parties right
and i've been asked will you debate the
other third parties
and my answer is no because we need to
be on the debate stage with the
democrats and republicans
we are the only political party other
than the democrats and republicans
to have a presidential candidate on the
ballot
and back-to-back presidential elections
you know we have
joined the adult table and that's the
way we need to be treated
and it is frustrating but of course the
democrats and republicans they don't
want us anywhere near
because we're going to show that there
is a real alternative
and we keep hearing the media talk about
um
uh talk about you know two old rich
white guys
and i would say that's not even the
worst part the worst part is
neither of whom is going to let you make
your own decisions neither of whom
is going to let you spend your own money
neither of whom is going to bring the
troops home and neither of whom is going
to do anything about crushing health
care costs
and so i've been telling people hashtag
fake debates
because if we don't get the message out
there then
people aren't going to see a real
alternative because there's really not a
big alternative you know
they create a lot of fake drama but
they're both big government people as we
saw with trump
and so now we'll just have to wait and
see what happens and
we hear the you know the debate
commission who of course is
made up of half democrats half
republicans you know oh it wouldn't
serve the american people you know too
many people on stage
forgetting that you know we saw what
nine democrats on the stage at a time
and they can't have three or even four
and also um when you look at the debates
limiting it to two it's not there to
help the american people it's there to
help the democrat and republican party
they truly
do have a monopoly on that all right so
let's back up for a second because you
mentioned that 50 years ago there was
this debate whether the libertarians
were even
run a candidate so for for some people
that are watching this right now
that don't fully get what a libertarian
is can you do
libertarian 101 and sort of
what is you know the the reason that
it's so hard to
herd these cats is when you talk to
libertarians there's always someone that
wants less government so you get it to
less and then someone says less and then
someone says less and less and less
until you're endlessly you know everyone
it always ends in the debate about
driver's licenses or something like that
what is what is a libertarian to you
i say a libertarian is somebody who's on
your side
and not the side of the politicians the
bureaucrats the lobbyists and the
special interests
and i tell people that you know best
what's best for you
and not the people in washington pure
and simple you should be able to make
your decisions about education
health care uh retirement
all of these things that are going
through the government you should be
able to make your own decision about
yeah do you ever think that in a in a
weird way
or i guess in a depressing way at some
point that the ship has sailed that
explaining to people why government
shouldn't be involved or why you should
keep more of what you've earned or all
of these things
that it's sort of what we talked about
earlier but but intellectually they get
it but it's sort of like they can't even
fathom a life where the government
wouldn't do all of these things
well you know i was disheartened for a
while however
with kovid i'm seeing that no we haven't
lost our individualism
i was so ecstatic to see those people
uh storming around the michigan state
house
saying hey we're the land of the free
home of the brave you can't lock us up
like this
or to see the dallas hairdresser or to
see
well even the the shots we've seen of
nancy pelosi being a hypocrite
i think people are finally saying hey
wait a minute this isn't what america is
supposed to be about
and so i think they're now feeling you
know libertarians
you know people like me who joined the
party decades ago we've
always had this yearning to have freedom
and to have more liberty in our lives
but i think the average person probably
didn't feel it they didn't feel
big government upon them until recently
and they're being told they have to wear
a mask wherever they go and they're
being told nope
you're under house arrest you got to
stay home you can't go to your job
and and people i think are beginning to
question it
yeah so what is the the proper
libertarian response
to to covet and lockdowns and everything
else if you were president right
or no if you were president in february
and if you were president
right now what what would be different
well the biggest biggest mistake that
trump made was he didn't get the fda
out of the way and again when people ask
me why i'm running for president
it's because government is too big too
bossy too nosy too intrusive and the
worst part is they hurt the very people
they're trying to help
the fda is an excellent example of that
that with the fda there were dozens of
testing kits that we could have had
but the fda blocked them originally we
were only allowed to have two of them
so meanwhile southeast asia they're
doing extensive testing seeing who needs
to stay home and who can go out and work
in the meantime we're shutting down our
economy and on top of that we had dr our
we had
trump up on stage with dr fauci saying
you know what if you don't have symptoms
no need to get tested well at the very
time he said that they knew that over
half the people at least that was
the wisdom at the time that over half
the people who had the virus had no
symptoms at all so no that's the time
you need to have testing when you don't
know if you have it or not
and what about the lockdown specifically
yes well uh what about about the
the testing specifically that we
basically they were locking us down
because they didn't know who would be
healthy enough to be out on the streets
so how about testing us uh letting us
test ourselves and then we would know
and here's the irony from my part is one
of my grandfathers
is from sweden and his family immigrated
here
to have freedom uh to have the freedom
that they didn't have in sweden
and yet sweden's uh stores and
shopping malls and educate restaurants
and
and schools all stayed open so they're
able to move around freely
meanwhile we supposedly the land of the
free that people
immigrate to for freedom we're all under
house arrest so that's just a travesty
so it's just rather ironic that my
family came here for freedom
and yet the old country was giving them
more freedom at least with in this
regard
right so would you have left the
decisions about
lockdowns up to the states because in
effect that's what trump basically has
done i i assume
that that you're okay with that right
you wouldn't have wanted this to be a
federal mandate
well again actions speak louder than
words trump was
encouraging the states to lock down i
think the governors were following his
lead because the president
is in a role of leadership and i think
they were only doing what he wanted them
to do so now he's saying open back
up we had but you already told us to
close down so
uh he shouldn't have given that message
to begin with
and what frustrates me is it's one more
example
where people are thinking that they only
have one decision that that we should
all vote and have one decision
and you know people are under the
mistaken impression
that if the government doesn't tell us
to wear masks we're not going to wear
masks
and walmart shot that down walmart has a
policy where
you have to wear a mask if you're if you
work there if you're a vendor
if you're a shopper whoever you have to
wear a mask and walmart
so why can't we have a world in which we
vote with our feet or vote with our
dollars if we want to wear a mask
then we go to walmart and if we don't
want to wear masks we go to other stores
why can't we have that
and it's really frustrating because on
my local news show
the gov the my mayor of the city where i
live
required started requiring a mask for
all grocery stores
and drugstores and so they do the man on
the street you know interview
asking do you think we should have our
masks and sure some people are saying
yes it's a good idea
other people were saying no and it was
frustrating that nobody said
well wait a minute how can we all have
to follow the same rule
and that's what i try to get across the
idea with libertarians is
how about we each do what we want to do
and we don't need the government telling
us to wear masks there are plenty of
people who'd wear masks anyway
right so i'm with you on that that it
can be up to the store it can be up to
the restaurant
and they can figure out whatever
policies if they want people to wear
masks they want people to take their
temperature
or whatever it might be i'm actually
completely on board that what would your
counter argument be
then to the people who would say oh well
if you leave it just up to the
individuals
that people are going to do whatever
they want and that then will cause more
of a spread
well again you don't have to go outside
for instance my mother was in the
high-risk group and so she just didn't
go to the grocery store and her friends
went for her so
there's no rule saying that you have to
go outside and go shopping or go
anywhere
so i would say that you know the gov
nobody's putting a gun to your head and
asking you to walk the streets or going
into specific grocery stores
and also again that's just giving the
impression
that we're too stupid to do anything on
our own and if you look there was a
survey that was done
sometime maybe around april early may
where when some of the places were
starting to open up and they asked
people do you think we're opening up too
early
and the polls showed that something like
70 of the people thought that we were
opening up too early
so it just shows that even in a free
market people
would be a little leery and would be
taking precautions
yeah all right let's let's move off
covid and and talk about the
the other big thing that's happening at
the moment obviously there are the
protests and
and the riots and antifa and black lives
matter and the rest of it
um a couple weeks ago you sent out a
tweet that
seemed to support the black lives matter
movement specifically and i know you got
a lot of pushback on that
uh can you just sort of lay out what you
were tweeting and then
i don't know you didn't quite walk it
back but there was a little bit of an
exchange about it
yeah yeah it was a typo from a staff
member
who had capitalized black lives matter
as as in the movement as in the marxist
group
now let me point out that not all of the
people who are marching
out there with black lives matter are
part of the national marxist party and
of course
you know libertarian would be the
opposite of marxist
however if you look we share so many
concerns
we share uh you know the pleas the uh
the qualified immunity right uh no knock
raids
uh the racist war on drugs so there are
all these things
all these problems that we agree with
them on the problem is we see a
different solution
they want to go for more government
whereas we see
less government as the answer and i was
able to meet with a local black lives
matter leader who again nothing to do
with the
with a major group and i i spent the
whole day with him and i sat down and
explained the free market to him
and uh by the way he's a black preacher
he had
previously been in prison and we had a
great talk
and and he said yeah this makes a lot of
sense
and the one thing he didn't know and
this is the message that i've been
trying to get out
is for instance we all heard about rosa
parks right
the heroic black woman who refused to
sit on the back of the bus
well what they're not telling you is
that that was a government-run
government-owned bus and that at the
time 60 percent of the bus ridership
were blacks
so if you look at in a free market like
today with uber
what if uber were to discriminate
against the best 60
of their customers they would go
bankrupt as well they should
and i explained this to him and he said
wow
no i didn't know that was a government
bus and yeah you're right
they would go out of business and so
when i explained how government had no
accountability he said yes that makes a
lot of sense
and so if we can you know back to kind
of the educating
if we can kind of show to these people
look you're going to the very people who
are causing these problems
maybe we can uh get somewhere yeah it is
interesting because some of the stuff
that's overlapping
i always find that the the lefties or
the marxist progressives they always say
okay we've got a problem
with the government and our solution is
more government and the libertarians say
okay
we got a problem and our solution is
less government it's it's it's hard to
get them to understand
that but if you can i think that that's
probably the inroads for you guys
i'm curious with that in mind yeah with
that in mind where do you stand on the
1964 civil rights act because
i've had some interesting debates with
libertarians
on whether it should have been passed or
not and then if you if you say no it
shouldn't have been passed
immediately of course you're called a
racist but there are some
limited government principles that i
think do make
sense as to why you wouldn't pass it
usually it ends up with everyone saying
okay well we just shouldn't relitigate
it
yes so i have no problem with it being
passed when it was passed keep in mind
that was
this was shortly after rosa parks and so
there was systemic racism in government
there still
is and so if government is the problem
then yes of course we should have rules
that government fixes it
however i would say that right now the
free market can do a much better job
than the government
what they should have done was they
should have had sunset laws or something
like that
because keep in mind what happened was
uh
immediately after they freed the slaves
the
blacks were doing great they were
skilled craftsmen they were offering
their services
at a lower price to get their foot in
the door which by the way that's what i
did when i started my own business you
know hey try me out
i'll give you a lower price and so they
were wildly successful
and so the whites what they did was
instead of saying
how can we compete with them i guess
maybe we should lower our prices too
they said no what laws can we pass and
so they started
these laws to where you know you can't
be a wood carver if you can't read at a
fourth grade level whatever so
so it was through the power of big
government that we got here
so that's the only reason why i don't
mind the 1964 civil rights act because
it was because government was a problem
so government needed to fix it but
and and i've gotten i've gotten um
criticized for bringing this example up
but the thing is is
you can before you can be against it but
that's what the whole that's what the
free market is all about
sometimes we don't like what the free
market does sometimes we do but
uh you may have heard of the case where
this woman who worked for this large
company
uh put all lives matter on her facebook
and she was fired and the key here was
she wasn't
you know it wasn't a company facebook
and she wasn't
discriminating against an employee a
subordinate
customer vendor anybody completely
outside and yet she was fired
so this shows me that the tide is
turning and the free market can handle
this
better than the government because we've
got the profit motive involved now a lot
of people said well
that's not what we mean well you know
sometimes you don't like what the free
market does
but it's it's society showing where its
values are and i think society's values
have come a long way and i think that
the average american has much better
values and much less discriminatory
behavior
than the government does well i always
find it funny when people say if you
rolled back some of these laws if you
got the government
out of the way that suddenly people
would be opening up rest white only
restaurants and it's like well
most people that open restaurants i'm
pretty sure it's because they want to
serve
food it's not because they're racist and
if it was if there was a
whites-only racist restaurant i'm pretty
sure you wouldn't go there and the
market
would crush it so i'm with you on that
but you did say one thing that i that i
do want to clarify so i
i understand why you were saying that
there was systemic racism meaning that
the south had jim crolla's and and
the government could come in and fix
that but you said it
you said is or is currently that there
is currently systemic racism i don't
want to put words in your mouth
so can you describe well actually first
can you just define what you mean by
systemic racism and then give me an
example of
what it is today yes because i think the
definition is where people get lost
yeah systemic built in the system hence
the word system so
uh if you look at the laws let's say
drug use
right now um whites and people of color
use drugs at about the same rate and yet
six times as many
um blacks especially um you know
looking at people of color are arrested
and charged
than whites and you might say well maybe
that's just
they just happen to be there but you
know that that raises another question
but the other thing is if you look at
drugs that whites use
compared to drugs that people of color
use the drugs that people of color tend
to use
have longer prison sentences so uh
and and if you look at the prison
population it
with non-violent you know with you know
uh victimless crimes which
shouldn't be a crime at all you'll see
that they actually
are uh charged more in victimless crimes
than our whites
right so i think the part that confuses
people here
is that systemic i i think when i when
someone says systemic racism to me
that means that there are laws that are
in place
that are racist so as far as i know
there are no laws
that are in place that are racist i
think you're talking about the sort of
second order
of there may be more policing in certain
areas because there's more crime
so then and then i think what a lot of
people would say well that has more to
do with the breakdown of the black
family and why that happened
something like that right right well
first of all
uh to me systemic can still be part of
the
um you know the the organization the
environment
so if if um
cops are out there arresting people of
color at a higher rate
because that's either what they're
rewarded for or that's the hidden
message
or they're just outright told you need
to you need to go out to this
neighborhood more often
then that's still systemic even if it's
not written but like i said there are
written laws
for penalties so that
drugs that people of color use have
longer prison sentences so that's
actually
in the law yeah do you know of any of
those that are still on the books i mean
i know
i know that in new york city they used
to have the law about crack
got a higher uh sentence than cocaine
and it was generally thought that more
black people used crack because it was
easier it was cheaper to get
but i know new york city got rid of that
are there still laws like that
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah and in fact i
did check with
uh one of my respected friends at cato
to just check in i think about
uh three yeah maybe about three or four
weeks ago
and i said okay just want to make sure
that all these laws were talking about
before with um
the prison sentences and so on he said
yeah so i didn't go into detail just
because there were so many of them and
yes crack cocaine is one example than
crack and of course
now we get into the drug war and i can't
i have to at least point out that milton
friedman
told us that crack cocaine would have
never been invented
had cocaine not been legal it's only
because
cocaine was illegal that crap cocaine
was even invented
just like during prohibition uh people
drank less wine and beer and then went
to liquor because it was easier to
smuggle because it was more powerful so
uh and and so i've mentioned the racist
war on drugs and people have wondered
what i mean by that
again we go right back to the war on
drugs is hurting everybody of course
but um but especially uh with the
uneven prison sentences yes yeah so it's
it's interesting because i think what it
sort of whittles down i think a lot of
my audience is going to say the way
you're defining systemic racism is a
little
different than than the way they define
it which is why i ask that question
because there aren't specific laws or
there are if there was a specific police
department
that said arrest more you know arrest
more black people that's in our
code of conduct then of course that is
wrong but if the question is oh there
happens to be more policing
in an area that has more crime and there
happened to be more black people
there well then we have to figure out
why that is i think most people bring
that
again to the welfare state and the
breakdown of the family
and the welfare state is very much a
lefty policy certainly not a libertarian
policy
right absolutely but well let me just
say that
i agree with your listeners your viewers
that yes the free market can handle
uh these problems that we've had with
discrimination
much better than the government and that
now what we have
is we're discriminating against asians
trying to get into harvard
and go right down the line it's it's
it's gotten
completely out of hand and i completely
agree
yeah so on the on the drug part of this
i find this to be a really interesting
one because you know i always describe
myself as a classical liberal and people
always say well dave you sound like a
libertarian what is a classical liberal
and i always say well look
a classical liberal in in effect is what
i would say
a really sort of a realist libertarian
is meaning that
i love all the libertarian ideas but i
understand i can't win all the time
and i'm gonna have to put some some
guard rails there that that's the way i
the most simplest way that i would
describe it so in my book i talk about
the drug war and
and i'm for legalizing marijuana i'm
certainly for legalizing
um psychedelics and and then we can
whittle down every little drug but
i'm not personally for legalizing the
seriously hardcore stuff and it's not
because i want to put people in jail
because of their decisions
but but the simple truth is i know that
if someone
was cooking meth next door to me i know
that there's going to be more crime
and i know that that it's going to be
riskier to be out there and you don't
want kids there
and the rest of it so are you for
legalizing absolutely everything with no
regulations or is this a place where you
you find
some some middle ground i know you would
kick it to the states regardless but
but where do you fall on this yeah i
mean yeah the states right now
have laws on drinking and i was appalled
when i moved from a state
that you know you could drink pretty
much any time you want and then i moved
to the south and i was shocked when i
found out
what you can't buy alcohol on sunday you
know what kind of
where did i end up here and in fact we
couldn't buy alcohol on sunday until
pretty recently so
um so i you know yes i even though
i i don't like those laws at least
there's some
uh competition among laws unless you get
the federal government involved
and by the way i realize i'm i'm gonna
kind of leave the topic for just a
minute just to explain real quick
because a lot of people don't know that
you know we
had when i was in school in fact i was a
bartender in college
because i was in a state where the
drinking age was only 18.
and that's the way it was back then that
different states had different drinking
ages
until elizabeth gold transportation
secretary in the 90s
came along took in you know just like
government always does federal
government always says takes in the
money
and then dangles the highway funds in
front of states and says hey do you want
your
uh you want your highway money back
you're gonna have to raise the drinking
age
now we can have a debate you know maybe
21 is a better drinking age whatever
but the point is it shouldn't be the
federal government deciding that it
should
be the states so when i say okay
let's have the states you know you know
we'll let the states regulate it if they
like
i mean really let them regulate it not
have the federal government
you know back door in there trying to um
hold bribes over their heads so
uh they can do what they want so you
really so
so you let them do it
confused what you said because you said
that you wouldn't legalize the harder
drugs but then you talked about you know
having
um somebody having a meth lab i mean i
guess is a meth lab a harder drug or i'm
confused
yeah well well meaning i wouldn't want
if if meth was totally legal
uh then i suspect that more meth labs
would be popping up and i know that i
right now if someone moved in next door
and was cooking meth
next to me well we know it's it's
illegal and someone will hopefully do
something about it assuming we still
have a police department here in los
angeles i'm not sure but if it was legal
there would be no recourse and we know
what will happen crime will expand
you'll get shadier people around here
property value will go down
etc well i see it completely differently
because we've got
alcohol well alcohol is legal and i just
don't hear of many people making bathtub
gin
but that's part of the problem is when
you legalize something or decriminalize
it however you want to do it
is it has to truly be legal so for
instance in california they've legalized
marijuana
but they've limited the number of people
who can sell it they've got all these
licensing laws you've got to pay all
these fees
so they're still underground there's
still an underground market there's
still
people selling marijuana illegally so
that means the laws aren't right
uh again when's the last time you heard
of anybody selling bathtub gin that
would cause somebody to go blind
you don't because it's it's legal to the
point that
we go down and we buy it safely so if if
meth were legal
there wouldn't be people making it next
door they'd be making it down at philip
morris or whoever
uh seagram's you know whoever makes uh
the other drugs
okay so i so i'm not with you there but
i do understand the line of thinking so
that
that's just fine but what would you say
this is where the conservatives i think
see the libertarian movement as sort of
bananas because i think this is where
conservatives would say
okay i get freedom i get states rights i
get all that stuff
but you're telling me that in effect if
there was enough
demand for meth that phil morris
and unilever should start making meth if
the market demands it and we know that a
society filled with meth
is not great so the conservatives would
take sort of we want to
conserve sort of a functioning society
where the libertarians are saying
it's more of a free-for-all do you think
that's like a fair
it's just sort of like a philosophically
different spot
well i think they're misguided first off
if you look where
marijuana is legal you haven't seen
increase in marijuana use let's say in
teenagers and you haven't seen
it um basically abused you know i
i again we look at alcohol i'm right but
marijuana is not marijuana is not highly
addictive the way meth or
you know some opiates you know some of
the more hardcore stuff is
well alcohol is highly addictive
tobacco's highly addictive those are
very highly addictive in fact
our own surgeon general said that uh
tobacco was the
former surgeon general i believe it was
sievert coop who said that
tobacco was just as uh highly addictive
as heroin
so uh and and yet that's legal
but you know what we have right now is
we've got
drugs being illegal and so they don't go
for help
and even look at where it starts you
know again when was the last time you
heard of a liquor store owner going up
and down the halls of a high school
trying to sell gin
if it's legal and the profits aren't
there you're not going to have the
profit motive
for people to go out and sell it i ask
what when's the last time you ever heard
of a vodka addict uh
breaking into houses in order to sport a
vodka habit you can make enough money to
support it if it's legal
when things are illegal they tend to
cost 20 to 25 times higher so that's
20 to 25 times as many houses as you
have to break into and
so i'm looking at it and by the way i'm
not a drug user well actually i am
bourbon is my drug of choice yes bourbon
is a drug
and i i got a graduate certificate in
drug
and alcohol studies and i understand
that
the way our neurotransmitters work
alcohol is actually a very dangerous
drug much more dangerous than marijuana
um but somehow somehow i got through the
1970s in high school and college never
having tried marijuana i gotta admit you
know i'm a goody two shoes
but the the point here is there's not a
profit motive
you know well when people ask me about
legalizing
drugs the point is and they say well but
i don't use drugs so i don't care
i say but you should care if you care
about crime
you should care if your kids are in a
school because right now there's a
profit motive
to get your kids hooked on drugs and and
high school kids themselves will say you
know it's a lot easier to buy marijuana
than it is to buy alcohol yeah because
alcohol is legal there's not the profit
in there there's competition it's we've
got the free market out there taking
care of
it so how about let's have the free
market take care of the other things
and then if you do have a heroin problem
let's treat it as
a medical issue and not a a
you know a criminal issue but and also
i'm confused because you said
well i'm not i you want it to remain
legal but you're not for locking people
up but isn't that the definition of
if it's illegal then you do lock people
up i'm confused well no i'm with you on
the last part of that in that if someone
was addicted to one of the
one of the drugs that i think should be
illegal say meth or
opiates or something like that um i
wouldn't want to send them to jail for
that i would want to get them help i
don't think putting someone in jail is
going to do anything and it's just a
drain
sorry but but isn't that what illegal
means that
if you do it when i say when i say when
i say illegal
um i was sort of giving you shorthand on
that but when i say illegal i mean if
you're if you're
selling it then there should be a
repercussion for it a legal repercussion
if you're if you're just using it or if
you're mass distributing it
i see that different as someone that's
using it
um and again this is just this is just
one of those ones where i find that sort
of the
it's we're basically agreeing here and
then there's like this little space
where it's like okay
hadia there's a more quite a little more
of a liberal approach a little more of a
conservative approach
and a libertarian approach uh and you
can remain a good person and not totally
agree on it isn't that crazy
yeah and by the way you can think that
every drug should be
um legal even though you've never used
them and uh bourbon's your drug of
choice
[Music]
i'm more of a red wine guy myself oh
well you know i do have red wine with
dinner yes
if you if you're a red wine guy then
good
we're we're we're on the same run the
same boat
yeah all right let's just keep going
through just sort of the the biggest
hits and
sort of the big issues so foreign policy
it seems to me
that that trump has been pretty solid
on foreign policy in that it doesn't
seem like we're going extra wars we've
got a couple peace agreements that have
been signed in the last couple of weeks
uh he he's trying to tell the people we
shouldn't be in afghanistan anymore we
got some troops out of iraq
it doesn't look like we're going to be
nation building anytime
soon do you see those things as winds
and sort of what would a
purely libertarian foreign policy look
like
yeah we're in about 160 countries around
the world
i think we were in 160 countries when
trump took office and i think we're
still in 160 countries
so if you want to say we've made
progress because now we're in 159
countries well i don't see that as much
progress
and we spend more on military than the
next probably eight countries combined
so and it's making us less safe that not
more safe that's the worst part about it
so
no we need to seriously bring the troops
home and
if i were president i would turn america
into one giant switzerland
armed and neutral in which we protect
our borders
yes we should have borders we need to
protect them
however we shouldn't be protecting the
borders of everybody else
and i've pointed out of course half
facetiously here
we keep hearing how isn't france great
they get five-week vacations we should
get five-week vacations
well yeah maybe if we weren't paying for
their military we could get five-week
vacations too
why are we paying for everybody else's
military around the world
why should a taxpayer in alabama be
paying for you know france's military
that's absurd
and i was actually excited when i heard
that he was bringing that trump was
bringing troops out of
germany i thought oh finally a step but
small step but step in the right
direction
and then i heard he was putting them in
poland no he needs to keep going
they need to come all the way home they
need to come to the united states
again one giant switzerland we need to
protect our borders
yeah so it's it's interesting because
you've got obviously some differences
with trump there but when he says things
like you know you got to pay your share
to be a nato
you you fundamentally agree with that
sort of thing right that the u.s should
not well
yeah i don't think we should be in nato
i thought he didn't like nato i thought
he was going to get out of nato isn't
that what he was saying
i think well i think he was at least
saying that the other countries have to
pay their fair share or we'd get out and
i guess we
i guess we did at least cut funding i
don't know if anyone made made up that
funding
well i got a great way for the other
countries to pay their fair share we get
out completely and we don't pay
anybody's fair share how's that
problem solved so if we were to have
you know strong borders and a military
to protect the united states
itself um do you think we have any
responsibility
are there any situations where there
could be a genocide
anywhere else in the world or you know
an evil dictatorial regime or whatever
it might be would you see
any situation where we should get
involved to
help people that are not americans
not from the standpoint of the
government
now we heard george clooney you know
trying to help people
in ward warned war-torn sudan we've
heard
uh or syria i'm sorry we've heard of
other people going over and tried to
make
humanitarian relief missions you know
americans are very generous they're very
helpful
they want to go over and help people so
uh let's let them help people
but as far as the us military as far as
uh going in anytime we go over there
to do something good something bad
always happens
there's always you know they call them
unintended consequences
maybe they're unintended but they're not
unforeseen because anytime
you go in and you pick one side as the
winner there's going to be a loser who's
not going to be very happy with us
so i would leave it up to the very
generous and
very fair-minded americans to do
whatever they like on their own
and keep the military out of it right
is there an inherent problem there
though that if this was world war
ii that the united states would just be
sitting on the sidelines and that
you know the nazis could have taken over
europe i get we're not europe i mean
do you see a a moral quandary there at
all
well i'm glad you brought that up
actually many libertarians think that we
shouldn't have gotten
into the war but i'd like to point out
that we were brought into world war ii
when japan bombed us so i'd like to make
two points first of all many historians
say that the reason they bombed us to
begin with
was because of unfair tariffs that we
were in a terror for
and secondly uh they you know
we look at uh japan now i mean look at
all the toyotas and hondas we buy from
them
they're not going to bomb us today
because we're our best customer you tend
to not bomb your best customer
so you say you know when you say foreign
policy
um i also include trade in that and when
you look at what trump's doing
basically having a tariff war with with
china
i mean you know there's a reason they
use the term war
and i would say we need to get out of
any war with china
that we we there is no way we can get
into a war with china we have the
ability to obliterate each other we
cannot do that
and the best way to do that is to open
up trade
so just like you know we buy all these
toyotas and honda's from
japan and they're not going to bomb us
how about we do the same thing for china
let's open up the borders it's only
hurting the citizens
and of course i know you've heard you've
probably said it where
uh goods cross borders troops don't have
to so let's go by that motto
yeah is there any risk there that if we
just opened up
trade altogether that they can just make
things cheaper
and that that ultimately hurts the
american worker
what's what's the libertarian answer to
that i hear that one a lot
if they make yeah if they make things
cheaper then that means
the people in our country who are poor
can afford them and it means that we
just sell
other things that we're good at that we
have a niche at and
you know we've been great in for
instance entertainment industry
look at the percentage of dollars around
the world that are spent
on entertainment that come from our
country i mean there's
there's you know this kind of brings me
back to deficit when people
talk about aren't you worried about a
trade deficit so like china
you know selling other cheap stuff here
well that's kind of like asking me
aren't you afraid that you have a trade
deficit with where you buy gas
no because i buy gasoline from them but
guess what they take my dollars and
somehow they come around back to me so
we can't
look in at each thing in isolation
and i'm the opposite of an isolationist
i think we need to be good neighbors to
everybody around the world
both economically and militarily and
here's one example
where freedom works and freedom
is morally right where uh we can trade
peacefully
and uh prevent wars yeah
so we focused obviously more on on trump
because he's the president and policies
of the conservatives
what do you make about what's going on
with the democrats right now and what
seems to be a war between the younger
progressive lefties versus a little bit
i guess of what's left of the old guard
there ain't much left and i think it's
sort of summed up by
it's summed up by biden what do you make
about what's going on there
well but the old guard is still strong
and the thing that i've been pointing
out is how they muzzled tulsi gabbard
how they unfairly kept her out of the
debates
and what's such a shame is that the
democratic party
used to be the party of peace they used
to be the anti-war party
and they've got a great anti-war
candidate uh
tulsi gabbard by the way let me qualify
that and say great on
that position i mean i realized yes
she's socialist on the economic
issues and that's why i wouldn't vote
for her that's why i'm running for
president
excuse me but on the war issues she's
great
and yet the government is the the
democratic establishment kept her
out of the debates because i wanted to
quiet her down so
yeah the old guard there may not be many
of them left but they sure are powerful
and that's really a shame
and that brings me by the way just one
other quick point is
uh you know i talk about how the the
democratic party used to be the anti-war
party
when i first joined the movement and
people asked me what a libertarian was
what i would say is well we take the
best of both sides you know
we take the best parts about the right
about the republicans
we believe in economic freedoms and we
take the best about the left
that we're anti-war that we believe in
individual liberty
and now i can't say that anymore because
democrats aren't acting like democrats
and republicans aren't acting like
republicans and maybe it was coincidence
that they even agreed with us
and young people are shocked when i tell
them that as recently as 2012
barack obama and hillary clinton both
were against gay marriage
meanwhile the libertarian party was for
individual rights you know they were
advocating
gay marriage in 1972 i hate to say
advocating advocating the rights
you know not that everybody should do it
but advocating
whereas democrats that's a whole
different that sounds far
more authoritarian yeah
yeah the people at the top you know of
the democratic party they're saying gay
marriage should be illegal
and if you don't mind let me bring in
one other free market item here
the disney company in the early 90s
20 years earlier were giving benefits to
partners of their gay employees so once
again we've got the free market
looking out for the individuals because
they have to
to make a profit they want to hire the
best employees so they've got to
basically put into you know uh you know
about a peer pressure
so and you know going back to racists
and all those laws again
the free market can do such a much
better job than the government
at anything what do you make about
what's going on with biden do you think
something's wrong there
well i'm not a clinical psychologist but
even if i were i think there's some law
that would keep me from diagnosing him
but my answer is
it doesn't what concerns me is what he
was saying 10 20 years ago i mean
what he was saying 10 20 years ago as a
younger man that made absolutely no
sense what worries me
is you know how he thought the crime
bill was such a good thing to pass in
the 90s
so people are saying well maybe he's not
all with it now i
i would suggest he wasn't with it 20 or
30 years ago
all right i got one more for you i'm
gonna i'm gonna toss you a softball here
and just tell you that
as i as i think you know i have a lot of
disaffected liberals that watch this
show
i have a lot of what i would call sort
of new school conservatives and and even
old-school conservatives
um but but i would say generally at this
point my audience leans probably center
right
joe jorgensen make your make your pitch
for why they should vote for you
uh on november 4th i would say i
understand why you voted for trump to
the conservatives in 2016.
he came in as an outsider he said he was
going to cut the budget he was going to
cut spending
he said he was a businessman who knew
how to get things done and he would
bring the troops home but he didn't do
any of that and i would say to the
democrats
you know again the democratic party has
traditionally been the party of peace
uh they shut down tulsi gabbard they
shut down bernie sanders
basically you've got a very slick party
machine going on that gave you joe biden
even though you don't want him
if you really want an outsider then
please check me out and go to joe20.com
that's jo20.com and i think you'll see
that
we are really uh what you believe in we
are the ones giving you what you want
and i'm so excited to announce that
something like 75 percent of our
volunteers are from
outside the party because they realize
that they're just not
that that the two old parties just
aren't giving them what they want
all right i thank you for your time i'm
glad we were finally able to do this
and uh good luck the rest of the way
what can i ask you one quick question
sure so you voted for gary johnson have
i won your vote
that's good that's good joe listen i am
so frustrated
by what is happening with the left and
the destruction of our institutions
academic media institutions everything
else
and i at this point i see trump as the
bulwark
against that the ideas that you've laid
out here for the little marginal
differences we have
i think are are the right ideas my
audience knows that i i say that all the
time
um i don't think this time that i can
vote for a third party to
to be totally honest and i get you hear
a lot of that and i think you can
probably hear it in my voice that it's
not
the way i sort of want to go in a
certain regard but i think
trump has done enough on the big things
that i care about
but i'll be happy to discuss this with
you privately maybe the day before the
election how about that
gonna make one last plea to your uh
viewers
yeah which is many of you live in a
solidly red state
like i do uh you know we were one of
only six states to carry bob dole
your state's going to carry donald trump
anyway uh the red states are going to
give donald trump the electoral college
votes
if you want to send a message to trump
that you don't like that he's gotten you
bigger government
vote for me because trump's going to get
the electoral votes anyway
if you live in a solidly blue state like
california joe biden's going to get it
if you're not happy with what your
candidate is doing
then vote for me because in the solid
red and solid blue states it's not going
to make much of a difference so let's
send some kind of message
you know what joe that that is totally
in line with what i was saying
four years ago and that's why i was
fighting for gary johnson to get
into the debates because my thought was
okay if the if the libertarian isn't
going to win let's just
you know if that's just not realistic at
the moment i'm talking four years ago
then at least let's get these ideas out
there it starts with ideas
and if that's a policy or if that's an
idea that can get you to seed some of
these good ideas out there
ideologically i'm totally with you okay
well thanks so much i hope to be on your
show again hint
yeah i enjoyed it and good luck and
we'll talk again
thanks thanks thanks so much had a great
time if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell